we've been exploring future technologies
for energy storage on the grid
a lot lately to me it's the most
important technologies
humans need to develop in our battle
against climate change
solar and wind technologies have reached
maturity and are capable of providing
more than enough energy for all of
humankind for a fraction of the cost of
older fossil fuel power
and before i hear the same argument in
the comments
no they aren't cheaper because of
subsidies in 2017
the fossil fuel industry received
subsidies totaling
447 billion dollars worldwide
dwarving the 128 billion
renewables received despite renewables
providing a larger share of new capacity
installations
in 2017 at around 75
of total new electricity generation
capacity
renewables are cheaper cleaner and
sustainable
that's why countries are investing in
renewables
that's the point of subsidies it's
government funding for economy
sustaining
infrastructure and the faster we can
transition the better
countries will become less reliant on
constant imports of fossil fuels from
war-ravaged regions will create new jobs
in renewable industry
and not to mention because we are
looking down the barrel of a climate
crisis
that is going to send the world into
chaos if we don't address it now
the primary factor holding renewables
back today
is this energy storage problem lithium
ion batteries and other
novel battery technologies are rapidly
becoming the forerunners to form the
brunt of our energy storage needs
while hydrogen looks poised to seize
long duration energy storage
applications
however in all of this analysis we have
glossed over
the oldest and most dominant form of
energy storage
a simple method of energy storage that
converts electricity
to potential energy by pumping water to
an elevated reservoir
where it can be later released to drive
an impeller
when the electricity is needed pumped
hydro
is one of the oldest technologies still
in use in our modern day electricity
grid
it's a rugged long-lived and mature
technology that has provided an
incredibly
valuable service to grids across the
world for more than a century
there have been calls around the world
to increase our energy storage capacity
in this tried and tested technology
however as we will find out it's not
quite as simple as investing in the
infrastructure
to learn more about this essential
technology i visited
turlock hill ireland's first and only
pumped hydro station
construction began on this landmark
infrastructure project
in 1968 and after six years of laborious
excavation
the final components of the generators
were installed and became
operational in 1974. since then
turlock hill has provided valuable load
shifting services for the irish
electricity grid
requiring just one overhaul of its
facilities in 2012
38 years into its operation that is an
impressive life cycle
historically turlock hill has taken
thermal power generation from coal
oil and peat fuel stations which could
not be turned off at night
and released that power during the day
when needed most
however today it's become a valuable
resource as ireland rapidly increases
its wind power generation
helping the country to gradually
decommission those heavily polluting
fossil fuel plants
and replacing them with wind ireland
with its windy position
on the edge of the atlantic has prime
real estate to begin growing its
offshore
and onshore wind resources and with the
help of energy storage
can become a net exporter of energy to
its neighbors in the uk
and wider europe however the question i
find myself asking
is how many turlock hills would ireland
need to fully convert
to renewables to understand the scale of
the task at hand
let's imagine one cubic meter of water
we can raise its energy by increasing
its height we can calculate the increase
in energy
using the equation for gravitational
potential energy
which is simply the mass of the object
multiplied by the acceleration
due to gravity multiplied by its height
here we are defining height as the
difference in height between
our starting point and our end point the
mass of one cubic meter of water is one
thousand kilograms
so with every one meter gain in height
we add
9810 joules of energy
we will convert to watt hours here as
it's a more commonly used unit
9810 joules equals about 2.7 to 5
watt hours that's not a lot that could
run a 100 watt
light bulb for just 98.1 seconds
but we can't convert that energy
perfectly turlock hill
is about 80 percent efficient so that
would be closer to 78.5 seconds
if we raised it to 286 meters
the head of turlock hill that one cubic
meter block of water
could power that same light bulb for 22
451 seconds or about 6.2 hours
we of course couldn't drip feed that
water like this through a generator
over nearly six hours let's see how the
power station
buried deep within the mountain works to
get there
we drove down this tunnel it felt like
we were entering some villain's lair
from james bond
the tunnel is 600 meters long and the
granite rock was blasted out of the
mountain
using explosives until the desired
location of the internal cavern was met
here they cleared a cavern 28 meters
high
23 meters wide and 82 meters long to
install
the four 73 megawatt generators
deep inside the mountain the cavern
cross section looks like this
we enter the cavern here on the upper
level where the pony motors are located
these are electric motors which take
electricity from the grid to spin
impellers located on the lower level
which pumps water uphill
when we need to generate electricity
this valve also
on the lower level opens to allow water
to flow through the impeller
this now rotates the impeller in the
opposite direction
and drives the generator located just
under the pony motor
this is a single machine that is capable
of both
pumping water and generating electricity
there is no control over the rotational
speed here
it's a fixed speed generator locked to
the grid's 50 hertz frequency
however there are wicked gates between
this valve and the impeller
which limits the flow rate into the
impeller and allows the generator to be
throttled
down to 5 megawatts this is an important
feature that allows turlock hill to
quickly ramp its production
up or down with grid demands it also
features a compressed air evacuation
system
that allows the impeller chamber to be
quickly emptied of water
using a blast of compressed air this
allows the impeller to quickly reverse
direction
without the resistance of the water
impeding it allowing turlock hill
to quickly switch from generation to
pumping
at maximum flow rate water rushes
through the machine
at 28.3 cubic meters per second
for a total of 111.3 cubic meters per
second
if all four 73 megawatt generators are
used
that is an ungodly rush of water 111
metric tons of water
every second at this flow rate the 2.3
million
cubic meter upper reservoir would be
drained in a little over
five and a half hours when this valve
opens to the water pressing down on it
with the force of 29 atmospheres
you can feel the ground beneath you
shake i was in the driveshaft access
room
during generation and the power behind
it was truly
awe-inspiring this massive chunk of
steel
rotates at 500 revolutions per minute
driving the rotors
to rotate inside the magnetic stators to
generate
73 megawatts of power that's an enormous
quantity of water
and electricity it felt like the entire
mountain was shaking around me
together these four generators can
provide up to 292 megawatts of power
capable of providing about 4.8 of
ireland's total electricity needs
at its peak demand of about 6 000
megawatts which occurs
at about 5 30 pm every day this
is a truly massive battery that helps
ireland
immensely in smoothing out its erratic
wind generation
over the last month this is what wind
generation in ireland looked like
going to a maximum of 4 249 megawatts
over 80 percent of ireland's maximum
demand
to a minimum of 300 megawatts just 5
of the maximum demand thankfully
ireland's grid operator has become
incredibly skilled in forecasting wind
generation
using weather data this graph shows the
actual wind generation
and this is the forecasted generation
this ability to predict what power
will be available ahead of time allows
ireland's grid operators
to predict when quick response
generators like turlock hill
and natural gas power plants will need
to kick in and take up the slack
going forward though we will want to
completely eliminate
this natural gas generation so let's
look at the average
natural gas generation in ireland and
figure out
how much pump storage would be needed to
replace it
this will be a little imprecise and
won't account for many scenarios
but we can get a general idea of the
challenge that awaits us
i started by downloading the generation
data from the irish grid dashboard
website and found the average generation
for the past month
which came out to 4840 megawatts
over that period roughly 50 percent of
power generation
came from fossil fuels so let's say we
need 2
420 megawatts of power generation
that would require 8.3 pumped hydro
stations
like turlock hill to satisfy this demand
at any one moment
but the problem is turlock hill can only
run for five and a half hours at peak
generation
this power generation would need to be
available 24 hours a day
so we are going to need four to five
groups of eight pumped hydro stations
available to come online at different
periods of the day that would require
about 37 stations of equivalent size
now keep in mind that ireland is a
relatively sparsely populated country
new york city has a larger population
than the entire island of ireland
37 facilities like this for such a small
population
is a massive undertaking if we were to
create
one massive reservoir with the same head
as turlock hill
that reservoir would need a volume of 85
million cubic
meters that is roughly the same volume
of ireland's
ninth largest lake and trying to find
space for that
on top of large hills and mountains
isn't easy
finding suitable sites for pumped
storage is difficult
extremely difficult we need not one but
two reservoirs
capable of holding massive volumes of
water separated by a meaningful height
at least 200 meters but the horizontal
distance between the two reservoirs
needs to be relatively short as a long
passage between the upper
and lower reservoir will result in
greater energy losses
due to friction and viscous fluid
effects
the cost of boring the tunnels between
the reservoirs will also be higher
typically the cutoff point is defined by
a ratio of head height
to horizontal distance anything greater
than 1 to 10
is usually deemed uneconomical so a 200
meter head
could have a maximum horizontal distance
of two kilometers
between the reservoirs turlock hill has
a head to height ratio of about 1.5
next the site needs to be relatively
close to population centers
to avoid transmission losses or
expensive
purpose-built high-voltage transmission
lines to connect to a distant grid
we also need a supply of fresh water
which is a much
larger logistical issue than people
anticipate
fresh water resources are valuable and
interfering with them
often comes with environmental concerns
even with a closed-loop storage system
like turlock hill where water is just
swapped from one reservoir to the other
without an outflow this water can
evaporate over time
thankfully it's rarely sunny and rains
so often in ireland that any evaporation
is more than replaced by groundwater
gathered by the lower reservoirs
catchment area
because finding suitable sites for
pumped hydro storage is difficult
we've designed algorithms that scour
over databases of map data
looking for suitable sites and there are
plenty of proposed sites currently vying
for planning permission
or already under construction but there
isn't enough to satisfy
our total energy storage needs ireland
has just one
active site seeking permission to begin
construction
the estimated cost of the facility will
be 948 million dollars
and will use a disused strip mine as its
lower reservoir
it now has eu backing but still hasn't
begun construction
a decade after first being proposed the
combination of high initial capital cost
and environmental concerns often block
the few suitable sites
we can't find this progress is too slow
to this end some companies are looking
to fix these problems
a pumped storage facility that used salt
water instead of fresh water
would open some locations where fresh
water is scarce
a seawater pumped storage facility was
tested
to limited success in japan but that
experimental facility
eventually closed due to lack of demand
for the electricity
this could open many new possibilities
and would be particularly valuable for
places like california
where fresh water is a valuable asset
and solar energy
is abundant one such facility was
proposed in county mayo
in ireland on this large flat-topped
mountain
directly next to the sea a flat-topped
mountain of this size could house a
massive upper reservoir and simply used
the atlantic ocean
as its lower reservoir others like quid
net energy
are looking to instead pump water into
underground rock layers
under pressure which would then be
released to drive a generator when
needed
pump storage is a reliable and long
lasting energy storage method
it's not going anywhere it is coming
under pressure from competition from
cheaper batteries
that don't require massive 1 billion
dollar investments
but its ability to store energy for
longer durations
will ensure its continued use one energy
storage method
isn't going to fix this problem we are
going to see a world where multiple
methods are used
this graph taken from a fantastic paper
on levelized cost of storage
shows the mix ic being utilized by 2050
a combination of several forms of
batteries for fast frequency response
and short duration load shifting with
pumped hydro being used for longer
duration storage
from 12 to 72 hours while hydrogen
is the only feasible method for longer
duration storage
there won't be just one solution that
solves this energy storage
crisis this problem is going to need a
holistic analysis of the grid
and its needs electricity generation is
just one aspect of how humans need to
adapt
to a more sustainable existence on this
planet
we have a long way to go in our quest to
avoid climate disaster
this video was created in partnership
with bill gates
inspired by his new book how to avoid a
climate disaster
which approaches this problem with the
exact holistic analysis i mentioned
above
you can find out more about how we can
all work together to avoid a climate
disaster
with the link below
[Music]
you